moi je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
reproches très sévère à faire au
président erdogan
mais je crois que lui faire ce reproche
la de manière aussi forte qu'on a pu le
faire
ça montre plutôt je dirais c'est un
indice plus tôt de nos lâchetés plutôt
que reproche véritablement fondée
la vérité c'est que l'europe est en
désordre total lorsqu'elle sort à
l'étranger que la présidence du conseil
européen
incarnée par monsieur michel et la
présidence de la commission européenne a
incarné par madame vers les jeunes
pousses imper' d'effacer ces
suppressions la télévision se tirent la
bourre depuis toujours pour savoir qui
précède l'ordre dans l'ordre
protocolaire s'est clairement monsieur
michel donc l'europe arrive je dirais en
ordre de bataille interne
les turcs sont un rempart ou seulement
par pas nous nous agitons 1 à 1 102
reproche de de sexisme
alors que très sincèrement il ya
d'autres reproches à faire le président
erdogan avait fait arrêter juste la
veille ou l'avant-veille une dizaine
d'amis héros qui n'étaient pas d'accord
avec à sa vision de doubler le canal du
bosphore ça voilà les violations des
droits de l'homme il est vrai que la
turquie est sorti de la convention
d'istanbul qui est censée protéger les
femmes et les enfants des des violences
conjugales
mais je crois que air de galles est un
véritable provocateur s'il avait voulu
provoquer il serait allé un tout petit
peu plus loin disons que peut être que
le protocole turc s'est servi déshérence
et des ambiguïtés du protocole européen
pour juste boucher au passage l'europe
encore une fois l'essentiel n'est
vraiment pas là et que nous attardions
là tu montre bien que nous ne comprenons
pas ce qu'est la turquie et deuxièmement
ne comprend pas les problèmes qu allah
et des problèmes qu'elles se posent
[Musique]